head coach of Clemson Tiger football the
head of the program the coach Dabo
Swinney back here on the show good to
speak with you again coach you're just
gonna be ready rich how're you doing I
am doing better for talking to you
what's the most asked question you get
walking around campus they're right
around now coach am I gonna you know
since Rich Eisen has improved his forty
times why consider bringing him on board
to to catch some of the passes yep from
his quarterbacks I got so what you think
well you know what coach I appreciate
that since I know you are a molder of
professionally fast men and send them to
the next level to ball out and go to Pro
Bowls so I appreciate that
so do I do I have DeAndre type ability
based on what you see on tape well you
know I love your effort and your heart
you know and you want to I mean those
are three great things that you got to
have you know but but in reality you
know probably better off with where you
are right now for sure
I appreciate the tough love see that's
why you're as good as you are it's the
tough love right there I've said I got
the tough love right appreciate that
because you can't teach what beats
inside you know you know that for sure
if I could put what you have inside of
you know some of these incredibly gifted
athletes you know I would probably never
lose a game there's no doubt about it
well I did notice you did say which
quarterbacks I did notice that you did
say that I did notice you guys man we
got some guys you know we're we're
number unique situation obviously we got
the guy back that that's won 12 games
and took us to a playoff in his very
first year starting and so he's he's
much much improved from where he was
this time last year is a guy going into
his really first year to play and then
and we've gone out and recruited a
couple very gifted players and
you know so it's just and they've all
been here since January you know
grinding and competing and and so it's a
good situation because we're really for
the first time since I've been the head
coach I think I literally think we have
three guys that we could win with so you
know I'm excited about that obviously
one of them is gonna run out there when
we play and you know we practice every
day we grade everything and it's sooner
or later somewhere online it will have
an end point and this is where we'll
start but I think I think you'll see us
play more than one guy you know probably
a lot as we go through the season you
know as long as they continue to play
well and I don't I don't doubt that they
will say yeah I was gonna ask you is
there any thoughts to having a two
quarterback yeah I mean I just you know
I think you played the hand that you're
dealt you're in you're out and to me too
you know I know some people that's kind
of taboo but but to me I don't see the
position is any different than any other
position I think if you have very
productive people you play them you know
as long as they're playing at a high
level I mean I could go on I mean we had
Shaq Lawson was big Beasley's back up
and both first rounders and so you know
we they both played a lot obviously
somebody had to run out there first and
and depending on how they played you
know was was maybe one guy got more
snaps than the other but so I don't
really think that's a problem and it's
just it doesn't often happen at
quarterback like that but I think we're
in a situation this year as long as guys
play well where were your poverty more
than one guy play if you could wave a
wand
Dabo Swinney or be in charge of the
entirety of the sport and could make a
rule change what would that be
oh man on the field or off the field
oh let's go on the field first up on the
field I'd probably do away with the
double-team on the kickoff return that'd
probably be you know the one thing I
think I think we've made some progress
there I think that's that's probably
coming
I'd probably you know do that you know
we still can come together and kind of
have that double-team block and that's
that's probably the the the toughest
play out there where I think you know
there's still chance for guys getting
hurt and things like that it's a tough
play I think if we made it more single
blocks you know be movement more like a
punt returner as opposed to you know
those wedge wedge blocks so that
probably the the biggest one for me and
what a hot off the field off the field
man I got a bunch of those I'd like to
change but I'd love one now just because
it's fresh on my mind when I was just
thinking about today I was talking to a
guy at practice but I would love to
because we're just coming off a
scrimmage this morning and you know in
college we're the only level of football
youth league middle school high school
pros we're the only level of football
that we don't get any type of Jamboree
or preseason game or we know we can't go
scrimmage against somebody else and we
don't even have to scrimmage we can't
even practice against somebody else and
I've always I've never understood that
we do it at every other level while an
even basketball at this level you know
has a couple of closed scrimmages
against other teams and just like in the
pros you know you you know you you can
go practice against somebody else I just
I think you'd have a little better
chance to evaluate your team you know
even if you had a preseason Jamboree or
something you know where you could get a
little scrimmage work against somebody
that's not your guy because you know for
me when we go scrimmage you know all 22
on the field somebody grabs an ankle or
they're all mine
you know hundred-percent invested and
you know each other you're very familiar
with each other it would just that's one
of the things in
that I would like to see but if it was
just a practice where we could do some
one-on-one pass rush and some inside
drill in seven or seven against somebody
other than your team at least once in
the in the fall camp I think that would
be great
well maybe something like that could be
done in conjunction with getting rid of
conference championship games and adding
a playoff team or I don't know what's
gonna happen down the road but but you
know I think I think all that part is
probably you know pretty much set in
stone I think til 26 and then they'll
review it again and go from there but
but I think if you def if you expanded
the playoffs you definitely would have
to you know change you know because
because to me that right now they see
the any of the championships ACCSC
whatever it is a playoff game because if
you lose it you're your there's probably
a good chance you're going to be out it
may be a rare occasion so I think
something would have to change there if
they ever did expand it would you be up
for the expansion of it I normally ask
that of coaches who aren't in it almost
every damn year but would you be up for
it yeah I actually like what we have you
know I really do I'm I'm kind of
traditional in that way I love college
football I think that I think we already
have that and that's pro football where
you got the playoffs and I think that
you know you just I mean you even see it
in the pros now where some of these
teams that are in maybe that last game
they already know they're in the playoff
they had that you know they just sit
guys they don't play them the game's not
as meaningful and I think that makes
college football very unique and that
every single game matters and its really
unique I think we have a good balance I
grew up in the bowls and I love going to
bowls as a player I still like watching
them some of the random matchups and and
and all that stuff so I think we've got
a good balance I know a lot of people
want to see the playoffs go to eight or
even more but I think I think it's been
I think it's been a pretty good balance
and college football's you know probably
as popular as it's ever been and
I think the more you go the more water
down it'll get but you know whatever
they say do that's what we'll adjust to
go do and that's my job is to go compete
but I think I think we have a good
balance of a little of the playoff taste
and kind of figuring out okay who's
number one as opposed to just the
old-fashioned way of just voting them
number one and then the computer doing
it it's kind of getting settled on the
field and then but still having the bowl
experience and the opportunity there as
well
a couple more minutes left with Clemson
head coach Dabo Swinney here on the Rich
Eisen show it was a couple of
appearances on this show ago where you
called
deshaun Watson Michael Jordan in cleats
and if folks did not have a first-round
grade on him they should be fired from
their talent evaluation position I'm
wondering if when you saw him perform
last year as he did in October before
blowing out his knee and taking the
entire league by the lapels and doing
what he did that you felt any form of
vindication coach who did I really say
that that sounded kind of harsh must
have had a bad day that day but anyway
sir well I definitely think if you know
people didn't have a first-round grade
on him they they were I'm not really
sure who would qualify for a first-round
grade I mean he's just incredibly gifted
player and to me it's pretty easy to see
I mean there's a reason why Houston went
all the way up to 12 to get him from I
think they were maybe 26 because it is
really easy to see he's a very talented
individual but it's the things you don't
see and that's that's what I always
tried to articulate to people about Sean
it's just it just makes everybody else
better I think everybody grows a foot
and runs a tent faster when he steps on
the field he just he just has that
uniqueness about him where you just
think you're gonna win and it and I
think that comes from high carries
himself what people see not where is so
much what he says it's just what people
see in him you know he is he is a
incredible preparer he's brilliant very
smart very instinctive and he just he
just is a winner and always has been
he's got a great toughness great Moxie
and and those those are things that are
sometimes hard to see when you're just
evaluating you know tape and that's what
I tried to articulate about him is you
know the best of the best out there the
Michael Jordan's and so on you know they
they were more driven about just
fanatical about their performance and
the little things and and and that's who
he is and just it was I was up or is it
look I wasn't looking for any
vindication I don't need to be
vindicated I I just want to see him do
well and I was really happy I'm
obviously disappointed he got hurt but
man I'm really glad that he got a chance
to go show what he could do and cuz you
don't just look up and do what he did
and the best thing might have been him
giving up is his first professional
paycheck to folks who worked in the
cafeteria in Houston well because
they've lost so much in the hard job I
mean very humble very humble that's the
other thing that I love about him he's
just a very humble person and you just
you just know he's gonna do the right
things and he's gonna always be there
and always be ready and and and I just
that was awesome because that's who he
is you know that's not something that he
did for publish' you know he was a young
person that grew up and a lot of people
stepped up to provide for him all the
way back to work done you know who
provided his first homes right through
the habitat program so I just think
that's who he is that's in his DNA and
very natural for him last one you got
farther you had far by huh you visited
your team yeah man yeah that was that
was kind of a cool thing for me I never
really got a chance to know breath while
although we played against each other my
sophomore year his last year or Southern
Miss yeah and so I you know I always
wanted to dreamed about catching passage
from Brett Favre and so it's pretty cool
to be able to play a little a little
pitch and catch with him I thank you
through the first three or four pretty
wobbly purpose just kind of check check
my ol sure enough see how I was going to
do but man he can still rip it I tell
you that there's a there's a lot of
teams in that league right now that
would love to have
well did you run what rock did you oh oh
I didn't run any routes we just played
we just were just ripping it back and
forth plans to catch and uh but he's
he's still got it man that guy can sling
it he's 48
I think we're he and I'm about the same
age so he looks great
heck he looks like he's in better shape
now and maybe when he was playing but
really enjoyed him you know I spoke in
an event back in the spring and that's
how we met and so we just kind of stayed
in touch and he came in and spoke to our
guys did a great job he was exactly as
you would think a lot of lot of great
stories very transparent with our guys
and I was it was a fun day and then he
hung around for practicing and I was
pretty cool to be able to throw the ball
around with him a little bit well I
enjoy our chat thanks again for calling
and coach really you always appreciate
that and thanks for the touch thanks
thank yes thanks again for the tough
love on the 40 at the top of the big ok
very good
that's that Dabo Swinney the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience